the gender gap is that phase a bit of a
puzzle first of all it's very badly
misunderstood I went to a conference
some years ago in which a prominent
civil rights lawyer said that gender
differences and test scores are the
canary in the coal mine there the
warning that something is really amiss
the next speaker who is not inclined to
directly contradict the first speaker
but did just by presenting it it said
well in fact in many subjects most tests
show women ahead and that's still true
there are differences math tests in
general if they show a difference
favored males not all of them do but if
they do they tend to favor males tests
involve writing almost always favored
women multiple-choice tests tend to
favor males but most of these
differences are fairly small the real
problem of gender inequity in my view is
a question of expectations we have a
society that does not in fact support
unlockable in my opinion does not offer
enough support to women and to young
girls who have certain interests it's
not considered in many cases the right
thing to do to become a scientist for
example or to become an engineer even
more extreme and so what you find is
that the the data show that as kids get
older fewer and fewer girls say well I
really want to be a civil engineer it's
just not something that is supported and
it continues it continues even in
academia you will find in some school
some colleges and in some departments
attitudes that make it extremely
difficult for women to pursue careers in
science I won't point to schools or
names but I've heard for instance of
cases were male colleagues have said to
him and you have to choose a career here
or children so I think the really
fundamental problem of gender inequity
is is simply one of encouraging all kids
to pursue the interests that they have
and then providing them supports I don't
think it's basically a
a problem of cognitive and academic
development